[Music]
we got a bunch of june bugs in the house
today um welcome back to the corridor
digital podcast i hope you're having a
wonderful day
and uh who do we got on the cast today
um who's that guy over there we got matt
matt karen's oh there he is there he is
oh i didn't know you were here
hey we got all the cool kids today see
ya over there we've got nick laurent
my bug catchphrase that's my little bug
and of course we have jordan coleman
everybody hello
oh that's so cool okay cool that's cool
i just came back from a peace rally in
san francisco oh yeah you're making up
jordan just got back from a peace rally
as matt just got back from joshua tree
there's a lot going on
we got some spooky stories we're gonna
talk about but but before we get into
that the spookiest story of all guys the
consumer price index is at an all-time
well not at all time but a very high
inflation high eight and a half percent
yeah
terrifying eight and a half percent
that means that the cost of goods is
eight and a half percent
uh higher than it was a year ago that's
why i'm seeing less money in my bank
account
yes that's why i'm poor
so i so me and my friend i have a friend
named matt he's a not not this matt i
mean we're friends too but yeah
yeah i have another friend named matt
who's a pilot and and matt has been
doing something um
to
combat inflation okay right so it's like
okay people get poorer a lot quicker
when there's inflation so what do we do
we got to slow it down he's a pilot he
travels all around
what he does is he has he keeps with him
at all times uh a a bunch of two dollar
bills
and he gives he gives those out
because when you give somebody a two
dollar bill they have more of a tendency
to remember who you are
than uh if you just use a normal bill
so not only do people
remember you better but also what's what
do people do with two dollar bills i
mean as soon as you get one exactly
exactly you put it in a drawer and
you're like hey remember that's the one
time i got the two dollar bill that's a
rare one
and and they're therefore taking money
out of the economy slowing it down two
dollars at a time how dare they yeah i
mean it begs the question if you save a
bill that would never have been spent
before anyway
does it still help the economy you know
you know two dollars at a time i think
this time will tell you know
you know
yeah there's like you're gonna need a
lot of two dollar bills to slow this one
so i get a lot of two dollars i get a
lot of two dollar bills because every
time i go sit at the americana someone
comes up to me puts a phone in front of
my face and they go hey can i write a
yelp review from your name i'll give you
two dollars what wait i got a terrible
every
no it's like it's their own personal
like say if all of you guys are at
the americana yes and i have a shoe
business
or something or i said juice i come up
to you and i go hey can you write a
review about me
and my company i'll give you two dollar
bill and every time i just go like this
just you write it from my phone is it
one person doing it yeah is it the same
person or multiple people right
three or two dollar bills in one day
jake's matt plane guy strats are someone
else is using this someone else somebody
else is on to it somebody else has
discovered the the technique i'm sorry
to say but like old like trained dads
have been handing out two dollar bills
for like where do you generations you
know what are train dads like like dads
who are like sneakers and like collect
and like train models and like they just
love like being the life of the people
that's very nice guys
is that the life of the party yeah but
they love two dollar bills is it like
hey i'm just gonna make them a dent
socially you know okay i'm gonna i'm
gonna make my mark it's a
conversation starter you know it is yeah
jake maybe you know this maybe not where
do you go about finding and procuring
these uh two dollar bills where do you
get something literally get them from
like any bank
can i get these ones into one two and
dollar coins exist too you know yeah oh
you can just do that that's pretty cool
give me a question
banks are required to keep a certain
maybe not but i mean they're obviously
required by the federal reserve to hold
a certain amount of reserve currency but
i don't know if if that has to be in
certain denominations
across the you know different types of
paper money you can you can carry
okay man
wow that's pretty easy though
rare money it's like rare money that's
absolutely not rare at all
uh you could yeah i don't know yeah you
literally could do it and they'd
probably have it
give me a fifty dollar bill and i'll go
okay see what i can do i'm about to yeah
i wanna try this out you're gonna go
turn up 50
yeah yeah i like it it sounds like a
great waste of money i'm i'm already
like a trained dad basically because i
carry dollar coins yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay
here's another i was i was going through
the airport security the other day and
some and one of the ladies i think she
was having a bad morning it was very
early but i keep quarters on me because
people quarters are cultural
quarters are yeah yeah sometimes and uh
this lady i i was like taking i carry a
decent amount of stuff on me when i go
through the airport but it's all stuff
that i use you know especially when
you're living that dad life like you're
gonna have the 50 cent pieces yeah
you're gonna have the two dollar bills
you're gonna have the quarters
and she was kind of upset at me for
having so many things in my pockets she
was like
overkill
it's like that's what she said to me
yeah as i was going through i didn't say
anything back i just kind of went yep
that's that's what i carry
um
because i didn't want to make her
morning any worse it seemed like
yeah it wasn't going well so
but i made me think of that because you
know if you carry 50 cent pieces you
better watch out nick somebody somebody
might call you out on that yeah you can
hear me coming a mile away just that
jingle jangle you know oh there's nick
he must have like two dollars on him
right imagine being at a grocery store
and paying for something in all coins
yeah no it would really when i was the
worker i'd be pissed yeah yeah that's
not cool scary are you carrying those
sacagawea dollars off
and it's cool because like they're mint
and like again it's just like if i'm
going to like like i always keep some
money in my car if i need a tacos right
yeah oh yeah good idea naturally they
take cash bro just want to want to hand
out a dollar so to a homeless person
because those are very frequent it's
like tacos
yeah that's the only reason i need cash
this is the most l.a thing ever by the
way why don't you give the tacos to the
home yeah that is very la i realized i
did start carrying quarters because of
how many people uh solicited me for
change when i was walking around
and i always had quarters because i do
spend money in cash uh
occasionally right somewhat regularly
and and so i figured it was you know hey
why yeah why not i i feel like in l.a
with the prices even you know like if
you give a if you give a homeless person
a quarter that's like a spit in the face
you know it's like yeah they can't get
anything like what are you gonna do with
that but like a gold doubloon
they're not just asking you either
i know it's it's uh
it's definitely interesting more
interesting to give a couple like gold
coins oh yeah hey that's very
food to nice that i don't yeah
like buy yourself something nutritious
is probably what i should say by
yourself just keep surviving some
lettuce
um water bottles you can also carry
water bottles like because like clean
water oh yeah probably more useful to
hand out true i have done that i've
given like i've had red bulls in my car
and i would give some a homeless person
remember
a static they were they should start
taking card honestly if a homeless
person is like ask me for some money and
i walk by him and i don't have anything
i'd have to save up enough to get that
little chip thing and they're like i
gotta i got the square app i got this
curveball i take card i'd be like yeah
okay all right you got me there you got
me i do it it's a thing
man they all take zell or cash app
nowadays
come on man
where are you going where are you going
to the dirtiest
grungiest dustiest taco stand right down
the street that's got the best ones i
think i'm right outside yeah yeah i like
pull out my card they're like you don't
[ __ ] do that here yeah and you don't
yeah it's like a slap in the face walk
down the gas station yeah yeah get your
dirty open get your dirty dollar bills
dirty use them on your use them on your
delicious stock i'm gonna get my nice
shiny gold coins jake okay
i'd have to go to the bank
i haven't been there and
yeah i don't think i've been to a bank
almost probably a year jordan's never
been in a bank
it's like online banking baby
baby
there's an app for everything i don't
need no two dollar bills
no
don't have an app for a guy who will go
to the bank for you honestly dude that
would be so useful because like what are
the bank hours bank hours are the same
as work hours it's [ __ ] up that's
probably why i haven't been and then you
can't go on sundays on saturday by the
time you even think of doing the best
get out of here get out of here who's
going to the bank
can afford to go to the bank but then
they don't have anything to do with that
they don't have any money
like make any deposits yeah right maybe
they count a couple unless they had a
card if they have a credit card
if they acquire
you know
with inflation you know
inflation affects all people even people
who are asking for change so yeah maybe
just think about especially people yeah
you know
it affects the poorest the most my
friends that's that's the main reason
why it is the biggest problem
um but scary that was just
that was just my introductory horror
story matt i want to hear about this
spooky joshua tree experience
so tell us all about it my friend of
course
so i went to i went to joshua tree last
weekend oh sorry sorry nick
we're talking about very la sentences i
think you just talked to me
nick's got a lot of uh fun facts about
josh it just so happens i have some
really crappy josh right well you you
hold on to those okay we'll get to those
later
when you need one yeah i'm sure the
folks at home really wanted to know
about
all of your fun facts about joshua trees
um yeah i went to joshua tree for my
birthday this weekend
and it was really fun i haven't been
before i'm an orlando boy and i have
lived here for like four years um and uh
yeah so i hadn't actually been out there
and it's a cool little spot it's a
desert it's very hot and it's very cold
at night
um and the stars are insane it's as it's
as dark as i've
ever experienced a night time
um
seriously
well i was a little scared because it's
so dark yeah you got lost didn't tell me
i got lost i got lost i got lost in the
daytime actually
we went on a hike and this is a side
story that i'm now gonna tell um the the
day of actually the day of the night
where it all happened
yeah we were on this trail and it just
turned into a bunch of rocks and stuff
and
we people just started disappearing and
we didn't see any trail head any kind of
like indication that we were on a trail
or anything and we kind of start to
realize that we're super lost right and
we're like um are we should we like keep
going forward or keep going back and
then we couldn't figure out which way it
was forward or back and then we're like
oh we're we're actually lost now were
you were you on drugs
no
not from the pesticides
no um
no so yeah because this is in the
daytime still all right so but we're
walking around
and just hoping that we can find like
you know the trail or whatever it is and
then out of nowhere this big like
bushy-haired
old
like prospector looking guy with a cane
comes out and no like absolutely no way
ask you for golden dollar dollar coins
but i wish he did well i wish he had
some one
instead of beating him up and robbing
him of his gold we asked him uh for
directions and he was like oh boys i'll
do you one better i'll take you back
down the trail and we'll uh we'll we'll
get you home free
and so the man walked us with his little
cane wow back to to shelter so where
does he live yeah i would love to and it
was it literally was not the trail at
all i did we got very lucky that we
found this old prospector man that lived
on the trail it was just like you found
joshua we found john maybe
these are his trees yeah
maybe he knew he knew of all the trees
can we go back how did you get lost
um well by by simply the trail that we
went on was if it was very poorly marked
it was a poorly marked trail so yeah you
know and there we kind of were like
excited about doing bouldering stuff we
were like climbing a bunch of rocks and
stuff and so we kind of forgot that
like
there were four of us but we weren't
really totally paying attention to the
trail itself all right guys just
remember to get back to camp would you
turn right to joshua tree yeah yeah
exactly you just turn right always keep
the joshua trees on the left
turns out they're on the right too [ __ ]
they're everywhere
this furry angel
a bearded leprechaun whatever what have
you yeah yeah anyway that's not even
part of the story because then night
fell okay okay okay and we're by the
campfire now we took an rv out all right
so we have an rv kind of campaign
great way to win it yeah it is it's
awesome it's within the park so it's as
dark as it can get right we're actually
in one of the darker parts of the park
too just so we can see as many of the
stars as possible
so the campfire had gone out at this
point and we're just like laying on this
big rock
and looking up at the stars
contemplating our light lives and things
as you do as we do um
maybe on drugs maybe not we don't know
we'll believe that
high on life we're high on life yeah um
and
sudden out of nowhere and it was pretty
far away we heard this scream
and it was like kind of sounded like a
human like a like a
like a kid a young like girl or boy
screaming and was like man maybe they're
just
messing around over there but then we
heard it
five minutes later again
and it was slightly closer this time
and we're like is it a kid because it
sounds a little like banshee-esque
it sounds like a like some animal human
hybrid
um and then uh pretty much five minutes
later
it happened again it was even closer
okay and then another one
came from a different side of us
so it was like kind of there were like
several of them around us it seemed like
or it was moving really quickly and
circling us
and at that point we're like
all right boys i think we should get to
the rv and probably
do finish this night like it was
it was either like yeah it was there
were either multiple of whatever it was
or it was like getting closer to us and
moving around it's learning and like i
don't know i still it still sounded
human
which is the weird part
even when it was closed i just got a
little one yeah even when it got closer
it didn't sound like an animal you don't
know what it was still no we haven't we
didn't see it we didn't know what it was
it sounded human when you got off the
rock there was nothing like haters out
there i don't know there's coyotes
there's lots of coyotes
they're gonna go out on the limb and say
that it was a mountain lion because they
do that yeah they're like shrieking i
know they do yeah
they'll sound yeah especially like the
whole like imitating like the sound of
an injured child hold on
hold on that's scary because it was
pretty close to us
yeah it very well could have been
oh man that's what that's going on
travels a lot out there though too
what's by the way noise travels a lot
out there too though yeah yeah i don't
know how close it was it sounded like it
was getting pretty close yeah
yeah
probably a good thing
that sounds like a mountain lion
is i think nick's trying to play it the
sounds of them
oh my god was it like that
it was
i can't hear it
it did sound like that okay it was a it
was a mountain lion
you almost got eight bud that's real
life i'm trying to get it louder it's
just not it doesn't it doesn't get
louder
uh folks just look up um
that it does it's a really like shrieks
of mountain lion sound though it sounded
like that that's why it was really scary
it's freaking out man
yeah i guess they sound really they
sound really eerie
yeah here i'm gonna put you back on my
little head now i don't know if they
have evolved to make noises like that
because primates are their natural prey
or if there's another reason for it but
definitely sounds eerie to humans that's
for sure well let me just uh drop a
little joshua tree fact here
nick has a collection of joshua tree
factory number five joshua tree has 57
mammal species oh
wow
one of those probably might have killed
us yeah
and coyotes there's a lot of coyotes
cottontail rabbits i'm not seeing
anything about uh oh
you'll occasionally find a mountain lion
a bobcat a black bear a cheeky coyote a
cheeky
we're a bunch of screaming mammals did
you hear or see any coyotes matt what do
you hear or see any coyotes i'm not sure
because that's all i saw i'm not sure
what i heard and so i didn't see any
yeah
i think we'd
we dissected it and it said landline
when did you go out there jordan
last year on my birthday
yeah i copied her yeah without realizing
it
and you heard you heard
groups of coyotes yeah me and mina are
actually lost
oh
we decided to leave our compound and
walk what's with everyone getting lost
well okay it's pretty easy out there uh
okay i got lost at night where i
couldn't see that's way worse
yeah no it's worse the fact that you got
lost in the day because you can like see
landmarks yeah i couldn't see anything
he ain't gonna be rescuing you i feel
like that prospector was not alive yeah
like he died like like 100 years ago you
know he has a soul
he definitely ran into the soul of an
old prospector yeah
but you know that there's a joshua tree
uh serial killer i i literally just read
that that's that's fact uh yeah that's
okay
number eight
numbers
yeah people we were told that right
before we went up there we're like sick
but we already got the airplane right
before you leave but yeah people come
they don't come back does he still keep
on a killing does he's talking about
he's scared about this are you sure
about this this is a real thing
all right
the quick version of william key's life
all right he started running scams at
scotty's castle in death valley after
having time for that he began working a
mining operation in joshua tree when the
mine owner went bankrupt keys took the
equipment as back pay and created his
own homestead blah blah blah blah blah
blah
a long simmering feud with another
homesteader landed keys in jail again
this time for murder
he was acquitted on a technicality
that's where you come in jake but the
tour guides will tell you with a wink
and a nudge that everyone knows he did
it so it could have been the ghost of
him okay this is the series
no i'm just saying i'm i'm reading about
i'm reading another name for the joshua
tree serial killer i guess this is hotly
contended there's multiple maybe maybe
william keyes was not a serial killer i
think he was more of it there's
after
being convicted of killing five women in
california and utah um there's one guy
uh that's that did that and but then
there's here's some reddit talk guys
some hotly debated reddit talking is
there any truth to this serial killer
rumor i've been hearing
in joshua tree um
i'm not gonna even open the reddit
article to see what the nonsense is in
there because that's
i mean it's obviously 100 factual yes
yeah but a man a 35 year old man was
found
dead
in january at the base of a popular rock
climbing spot i wonder how that happened
oh boy
was there a weapon found
uh i i don't know let's see foul play
yeah
there's like a classic like who done it
hikers die all the time body was
discovered a short distance from hidden
valley nature trail
um the girl was just i mean if you go
out to the desert and you're not used to
being in the desert and you're on drugs
and you wander off from camp it's really
easy to get dehydrated and like pass out
and then you can die or that's what they
tell people what happened
what the serial killers tell people my
friend said that uh the victim was free
solo climbing without ropes or harnesses
okay
what was
i'm going to assume that it was not a
serial killer but there is a serial
killer
i'm out
according to reddit according to reddit
there are some rumors of a serial killer
in joshua tree now if if we all lived
our lives according to reddit the world
would be number three horrific place
uh
well we went through inflation and then
joshua tree and then now
and then now the third horror of this
podcast is everyone lived their life
according to what people say on reddit
what's going on what's that horrific is
that our countdown is just is this
what's fourth what if we made a sequel
the yes man that was just you just did
everything people told you to on reddit
starring jim carrey you know that would
that would be um
a really interesting social experiment
youtube video yeah i did it i did
everything people suggested i do on
reddit for one week here's what happened
starting with um i was apparently
domestically abused growing up oh okay
cool cool i'll i'm in i'll do it the
bowling alley animations yeah that's
what you're supposed to do
um do you guys want another cool joshua
tree fact of course uh yes yeah
this one's really gonna blow your mind
joshua tree national park is big and
wild
fun fact about joshua tree it's so much
bigger than what you can possibly see
you can't even see it all in one
[Applause]
you can't even see it all in one glance
oh man that's that's rich okay this
say you is
is this what they're trying to get
people to
visit with oh man i don't know this is
probably like book your hotel now right
please book um it's probably this is
another one of those ai articles that
nico was talking about on the podcast uh
like two weeks ago
these these things have been
specifically these these blogs have been
specifically designed now to publish ai
written articles to answer like top
search inquiries of 2022
just to like drive traffic
yeah just to get the traffic and but
it's not any information yeah it's not
any real information you do you're
starting to see these i don't know if
i'm seeing these more and more because
of
the they're becoming more common or if
i'm just seeing them more because i'm
now aware of them
you heard about what happened
what was that that publication that was
like with ign or something that was like
offering like 20 bucks for like people
to write articles
yeah yeah it was like
yo you want to be a freelance journalist
we'll give you like 20 bucks and 50 if
it's really good like that's of course
they're having ai's do it i mean who
wants to write for them you know wait
you know amazon is doing something like
that too right
yeah i'm sure right
program called
amazon has
amazon marketing from
tangled just an amazon ai it's pot very
possible actually
okay seven well yeah what do you got
joshua tree is a dark sky park oh it is
it is indeed what the frick is it is
dark
fun fact about joshua tree national park
apparently at night it gets dark no i'm
not kidding i've never been somewhere
where i cannot see something that's just
like
twelve thirteen feet but i feel like
it's just gone everywhere though if
you're not here
or in a city it's everywhere if you
close your eyes yeah yeah this is just
like joshua true is the most l.a it is
nature you could possibly have yeah not
that it's a bad thing it's not no
judgment i'm just jealous because i've
never been there yeah yeah i've never
experienced the darkness i feel like you
should excuse me you should come total
darkness no flashlights no flash
flashlights allowed yeah even your phone
100 percent right there it's so dark
when you try to turn your phone on it's
so dark you can't see your screen it's
pretty wild i i can't remember what job
it was it's something data driven data
related but basically amazon has a few
of these different types of things where
they'll pay people hourly to like scrape
the internet for like
different types of data
um basically it's it's it's like a data
scraping job that
requires very basic human
um
computational skills imagine your resume
and it's like data scraping 2013.
oh man it was very dystopian i was
looking at one one time and and reading
about it and i wish i could i wish i
could pull it up here now but
alas
leave a comment down below if you yeah
if you guys know what i'm talking about
if you are a loved one ever
or if you work in one of these jobs yeah
they're probably not just saying yeah
they probably uh have to sign an india
here we go well it was like a coal
miner's professional like scraping as we
know from doing these ai videos all ai
stuff still needs a human touch so it's
like you know are they just hiring like
puppet masters to like oh here's a cool
topic and then just like yeah like there
must be some sort of authorship of a
human going into them like sam is the
puppet yes exactly
like they all have their own sam every
ai has its own sam that it's tethered
they all have their own sam yeah and
then they have to find someone to use
their voice oh dude survey junkie make 5
to 25 from home in your spare time the
easy way
try new products give your opinion and
take part in focus groups i'm not
kidding when i was super super broke
last week and i'm kidding
i would google like how to make money
from home but you don't even understand
i tried to do one of these surveys
it was page pages pages pages pages
i don't even think i finished it
yeah and you have to do like a certain
amount to even start getting like even a
tiny bit of money i didn't end up
finishing it because it was so long and
extensive yeah so 25 dollars is probably
like 48 hours of just doing it
wait a minute wait a minute let's go
let's go back i wanted to get somebody
from the comments to talk about this in
the comments we got somebody right here
all right let's see on stage
take us through how did you get to the
point where you were
taking surveys online
i was broke
yeah
yeah
so and then as one does google you just
go how to make money
right
and literally tell me how to get the
digi bugs if you were to go into your
google search and go how can i make
money from home super quick surveys is
always going to be like the top three
yeah for sure yeah but what they don't
tell you before you do your sign up and
make a profile
and everything
is that they're going to be like
70 page long surveys jesus i'm not even
kidding i mean i don't even know
especially when you can just go down the
americana and get two dollar bills
chucked at you yeah shop owners you know
like who would do that just have an
opinion he was just basking in the grass
like a golden retriever and handed a two
dollar bill
incredible
i've really come up from the surveys
online you gotta show that's quite an
increase of uh time
that's quite an increase of time to
value right there yeah indeed you know
for for
letting somebody make a survey
or make a comment
is basically like also taking a survey
but this one you don't even have to type
the comment you don't have to do
anything it kind of just tells you the
world we're living in you know when you
try
to make money yeah it ain't gonna happen
yeah but when you just sit there and
just sit there throw money in your face
got all the money in the world they just
throw it at your face don't they so take
that america
you can do whatever you want to do i
think what jordan is trying to say
is
life
finds its way with you and
your path will
yeah
will open if you are not just focused on
money that is the more gandhi way to put
it yes yes
or if you're absolutely loaded people
will just give you free [ __ ] all the
time yeah that's like so screwed up by
the way yeah you have to because they're
walking up the pipe i mean like it's the
same thing
yeah influencers celebrities free things
so that you can then influence other
people to buy them
you know this happens every day at
corridor guys right indeed it does yes
okay
it is what we do
here but like we we do get free things
all the time because people want us to
promote them
because we have a following it makes
sense
how things work back in the day when we
used to watch
a super bowl ad because we know this one
person from this one show or you're in
the i break it break it down jc break it
down
jordan can speak to this because you're
like if there's anything interesting
major in advertising
break it down for us you know
i mean i mean it's it's pretty simple
nick okay
listen let's listen okay take this one
of the biggest hit sitcoms jennifer
aniston right and then that's her that's
all you know we didn't have social media
back in the day you can't just go look
at her profile on instagram no while
you're in the aisle and you're looking
for your reese's cup before you check
out at walmart and who's that on the
front page of a magazine it's jennifer
aniston
i like jen right there yeah they do a
little headline title jen's pregnant by
brad or by
seth rogen i don't know right so i don't
have time to look so i'm going to grab
it because i care because they made me
want to care because they hit me with
it's like the original thumbnail
clickbait advertisement it is you care
about people because they're doing
things that you like you know or don't
like yeah you're like hey you broke up
and you threw your kids on the street
yeah people used to buy these magazines
gossip magazines they still do so now
the concept of us buying something
because someone is promoting it on
instagram is like not even like crazy to
me considering what we used to do do you
think that influencers have uh have
decreased the value of a celebrity when
it comes to influencing do you think
it's like it's kind of
i guess
like we're talking inflation do you
think does it influence inflation
has there been influence inflation
influencation
fluency
we'll workshop it well yeah next time
it depends it's a good time not every
influencer can
can promote every brand
you know
not every celebrity can promote every
every branch it still has to resonate
with that person and their personality
in order to promote it uh-huh
that's what they do on instagram there's
tears to celebrities too you know yeah
you guys are organic you get your whole
alphabet of celebrities that's true yeah
i wonder where like where youtubers fall
into that alphabet i feel like we're
around like
f
g yeah f well that's what do you mean
though and on scale of what i feel like
like like what i'm saying is a list
b-list
i don't think you can judge it by
platform really i think it's like the
quality of the influence you know that's
true yeah
but what do you mean like a-listers get
this and youtubers get this what's logan
paul because that guy you know he has an
influence right he's like if you if
you're just talk to someone who doesn't
watch youtube and say like name a
youtuber they play like logan paul yeah
everyone hates someone everyone hates on
logan
he is who he is but
in terms of his his the qual i'd say the
quality of influence on his audience is
like very it's very impressive
i would say he's a he's a top-tier
influencer it is yeah yeah it's
definitely obviously his you know he's
kind of faded from the limelight as as
much as you know um as he's gotten more
solidified and who he wants to be you
know and all that stuff um i think a lot
of a lot of people go through that where
they'll hit like
they'll hit height popularity height
yeah
and then they'll and then they'll sort
of like figure out
you know where they where they want to
be and how they want to be
and all that stuff and
um they definitely go through lulls
like yeah people become more popular
when there's either like a scandal or
they're trying to find out who they are
like jake said like miley cyrus remember
when she like left disney channel and
then she started doing all this like
twerking and like
tongue out and all this and she was just
like on every news article
it was the cringiest a cringy time in
america but now that she's just doing
normal stuff you don't really hear of
her like that anymore i'll show you how
that works yeah
it's almost like it's all big pr stunt
yeah
yeah
well yeah i don't know if it's all a big
pr stunt i mean there's definitely
something to like teen angst that people
when people act out especially when
they're like in their late teens and
early 20s that's that's a real thing
and if you if you get somebody that's
already popular at that time
then you know it's a very volatile
combination of of influences on their
life and then the influences go back out
and then all of a sudden you know what
do you do it's so shitty that they do
that to kids you know even just take
someone like just bieber
anyone that is just trying to find out
who they are and they are in the
limelight and in constant scrutiny if
someone imagine if you had a constant
camera on you
trying to figure out life and you are
and you just do something wrong
yeah you would just you would just get a
slap in the ass from your parent but now
it's on you know if you're bieber miley
it's on the front page of a
magazine that's crazy definitely a real
thing though i don't know if that has
been different throughout human history
like you think about people that were in
high society replacing that you know
children being like oh i my father died
and i'm now i'm the duke of york
what do i do i don't like one
mis introduction or like you know forgot
so-and-so's name or didn't dance with so
and so at the big ball and then all of a
sudden it's a scandal
you know
i mean that that that pressure i don't
know i don't know why people do that
though it's true humans are always
putting unnecessary amounts of pressure
on on people i think it's because we we
project our own desires for the youth
onto those people sure yeah they let us
down we get upset
and we end up holding them to a higher
standard just because of what they've
done a couple of times you know some of
their talents yeah like you're an actor
well you should never yeah it's funny i
mean actors
ancient antiquity actors were the dregs
of society you know like actors were not
respected people for so long it's only
recently not until the big screen guys
yeah no honestly it's like very
interesting to hear like you know acting
was kind of a shameful you know
line of work to be in right even though
you'd get these amazing you know
amphitheaters built and everyone would
come it was still like people loved them
when they were on stage but like then
you know yeah i mean you would get kind
of celebrities and like poets yeah
musicians but it's like gladiators where
they were still slaves yeah but you're
just you're just there for the
entertainment yeah honestly but but you
bring it up a good point gladiators are
the closest things we have to or they
had to the modern celebrities yeah
because way to the crowd when your
freedom
yeah dude i want to watch that movie
oh he's awesome yeah man not that it's
historically accurate really yeah well
yeah it's got elements of historical
accuracy and fiction
you know
what is ancient rome anyway yeah i don't
know there's a uh there's a tick talker
who's been going viral recently and
she's saying that ancient rome didn't
exist at all
that's a it's a patriarchy like uh
like a story is it intentional she said
no intentionally i don't know if she's
just like pulling a really good troll on
the whole history community or if she's
just really like could you please show
us yeah yeah i mean you can literally
just look up like this was like a couple
months ago to reach this peak and all
the big history uh youtubers have like
responded and like did their own
debunking thing so it's really fun to
watch but debunking whether or not
ancient existence existed yeah like
the most documented sorry the most
documented ancient society like we have
so much evidence for it this girl
yeah that's her yeah yeah um
it's just so silly it's i love all the
theories on the internet it's just ask
her to say one sentence and then point
out how many
words in that sentence are derived from
the language that ancient rome
popularized
and she'd have all the answers yeah
well she would just say well jake why
did the romans speak greek if they were
roman and you know
that's about the level of her like
intellect on the subject anyway yeah i
just find it funny um
that was just uh
i don't know how we got from
everything's justin bieber to that okay
so is that is that an a tier influence
or is that like a low tier influence
is is what the amount of people that are
on freaking tick tock i don't remember
the quality the quality of that the
quality of that well i feel like if you
take who's the biggest tick talker right
now who's like a big
exactly so like their influence is now
eight tier right they would be a-list
influencers
is is he lower than that like yeah
ai blogs are making these lists yeah ai
blogs make the list
he's well established i think it's like
directly related to like the value of
your influence too can i google that one
back to money here the a-list you know
it's like what is
what can your
influence yield monetarily for like this
whole conversation came out of the
concept of people getting free things
for how right much
quote influence they have sure the more
that i
you can only say that word so many times
in like a given hour before you start to
feel nauseous
i'm like halfway there yeah yeah
yeah
um
well that's but i don't know man i guess
if a fair place
if people find vegeta
sorry tough
no yeah the world will never what else
can you say about it it's like never how
we try to
to manipulate it but
that doesn't mean we can't be fair to
each other that's true yeah yeah
honestly that brings us to our sponsor
for today yeah it does actually we don't
have it we don't have a sponsor we don't
have a sponsor
it was a joke
but if you guys are interested uh you
get 15 off if you uh
sign up for quarterdigital.com so we got
that going forward oh true i do have
this listen an a-list actor is a major
movie star or one of the most bankable
actors in the hollywood film industry
technically you can't be a-list unless
you're i think in a film
though george
technically american entertainment
journalist james ulmer the guides
creator has also developed a version
including directors
jordan i i don't i don't
i don't know i know how to break this to
you but there's no true definition of an
a-lister yeah i will say that this is
also wikipedia
right hey i mean
[Music]
you are right though it's like the bank
ability like how much money can they
bring in is what makes you on the a-list
because the whole town is about money
it's all about money if you put your
face on it will they come exactly the
world's about and there are many
influencers where that isn't a thing
like people are like like really niche
influencers like you can't just sell
anything to your fans but i feel like an
alias hollywood actor could do anything
and there's a
a small amount of their fans but still a
huge number of them yeah i would buy it
so that's like
bankability i would just call those
people like creators and like you know
that but that's what they all are now
influencers are creators they're just
creating different things
because
you guys are over influencing the [ __ ]
out of me dude it's a craft it's an art
but they're not cree they create the
perfect experience but but you have the
screenplay you have a director you have
yeah but the actor just if you're just
an actor what do you i think it's a
craft
breath of life into a character's soul
jordan
being an actor
right but are you labeled a creator as
an actor a creator i don't think so i
don't know exactly that's what i'm
saying yeah but influencers have to
create content and that's what they're
labeled creators right
okay
[Music]
i think i know where you're going with
this i think these terms become relevant
to be defined when
the terms themselves become
necessary for economic use
i don't know
if they uh if they've reached that level
yet determining between a creator
influencer actor
it all goes like this now it's all
exactly yeah
you're totally right it's all like a
little bit of everything like why do we
even need a term let's just make up a
new word for it it's gonna be
people because
like you know differentiate people or
like label people that's what people
still need they still need labels so
it's like then you can't go too far it's
like you're never we're always going to
be screwed
how do we buckle up
how do we box up this person into a word
so that we can sell things against it
yeah don't you
birdman is actually perfect right like
it's like a little wayne like the rapper
birdman no no no no no the movie bird
man
it's like one of its themes in that
movie is that like selling of a human
like what is it yeah it took me a while
to like it's awesome
to figure out where to
place that
you know because all the brand
integrations that we do and that i do
yeah it took me a while to figure out
how to how to
understand them be comfortable with how
you know we were going to take part in
that and and its functionality to the
rest of our like business and and what
it was serving and stuff like that
it was tough because i remember the
first time i i started to understand the
concept of
when when advertisers come to you
oftentimes they'll say like hey what's
your guys's inventory
um
yeah
if i if i asked you that what would it
mean to you well hey what's your
inventory this season this quarter oh
gosh i
just gave you all my stats
i would say that too
yeah i'm going with that this is what i
bring in this is this is what i do so
it's it's
literally what they're asking you is how
many videos
do you guys have yeah
that we can sell
ads into or sell what they say it's
against sure um
but they literally they don't look at
the video library as like a library of
video content they look at it as an
inventory
for availability of placing
advertisement
um and that's necessary to a certain
extent when you're when when like the
the where it goes doesn't necessarily
matter and you're looking at it purely
from like a monetary spend point of view
but it also
like shows you how
the content is viewed
in general
by
you know non-viewers but to
for you know and so
it took me a while to i guess
be okay with even using those words
because yeah rejected them for a long
time um i i i yeah i feel you too
because it like kind of feels soulless
in a way whereas like you know these
creators have always like loved the
stuff that we make and yeah consider it
they brought it down they boil it down
to a unit of injury
yeah
yeah
i mean how do you think a celebrity uh
feels when they don't have a whole
company that they're representing it's
just like their actual person yeah and
yeah they're constantly just being
dehumanized and treated
right then
your whole name becomes that unit of
measurement you just become an absolute
unit
yeah
then every single thing you do is
scrutinized as a as a business and a
professional stance yeah it's certainly
a catch-22 i mean you know
like i think anybody who reaches like
high levels of of of famedom obviously
seeks that out to some certain extent
typically
um so the double-edged sword of that is
then
your name is now directly associated
with something that's like associated as
a product or as a brand
and that's
that that cuts both ways it's scary
yeah
that's scary all right scary stories
baby
scary story number four that's it right
there wow it's spooky scary story number
four is just like celebrity in society
yeah it's just the world we live in it's
just scary
all right final thoughts final thoughts
of the podcast jordan be real with us
how's this green screen built
going is it is this thing going to be
functional for what we need it for can
you explain to people what we're doing
is it a green screen or a green screen
because it's spooky hey cause it's the
spooky cast
actually because
for the theme of green screen week i did
have shrek on while we were doing it
yesterday which is very funny by the way
that's what i heard
yeah oh that's why you're watching shrek
i was wondering no actually i started
watching it last night before bed and so
i put it on you're like let's put some
green on the screen
no but the green screen is coming along
well me and uh see mike
we tested out
how to do the psych today multiple
different ways with different okay paper
what's this a lot of measurements okay
for those of you uh tuning in a psych is
um okay so we have a flat wall right and
then we have a floor 90 degree angle a
psych is going to go from one wall and
it has to go to the floor but it's going
to create a little
uh without creating a hard line that can
get caught on the green screen yeah and
we wanted to it's those little ramps you
see in the corners of green screens it
basically allows light to reflect off of
it evenly which gives the background uh
no in no horizon yeah looks like a like
if you went to a skate park and you know
you go up up and down can i can i ask
you a question to you jake that i have
not asked you but it's a legitimate
question about the um
what we're doing over there why are we
building a like a wood sike instead of a
because we want to be able to move it
you can move them you can make them in
pieces and put them up my dad has done
this every time he's had a studio my dad
is a photographer he didn't know he's
always made wood sikes they're a lot
more durable you don't accidentally step
on them and punch through them you don't
deal with wrinkles and the weird stuff
that happens when you tape stuff you
should get some papa tips from your dad
dude yeah my dad is very knowledgeable i
have a question what the woods like to
the wall does he make it super thin so
it's nice and flush to the wall um
what's that yeah yeah it becomes super
flush and you can actually put like you
sand it yeah you sand it and make it
super flush so you don't deal with the
tape the weird tape
shadows and stuff like that i think
eventually we should look into it
solution so here's here's the real
reason why we didn't do that the real
reason why we didn't do that is just
simply because time right now
and then also carpentry ability right
now yeah um so i didn't want us
i i
maybe nat
has this ability but you know to build a
quarter ramp like that it it does
require a little bit of
carpentry understanding
knowledge and and skill
um which you know no offense jordan but
you're still learning that stuff no i
would have i would have immediately
you know that was that probably wouldn't
turn out the greatest because we need
like 25 feet the other thing yeah the
other thing is the length of it and and
then also if we do move it and we don't
want it there where do we put it so
there was a few because space comes at
such a premium in the studio and also we
knew that we could very easily
roll out those
large
rolls of paper
and they would be functional for what we
needed it was kind of a factor of all
those things okay also i didn't know
that i didn't know how long it was going
to take natalie to do the props
so
i didn't i didn't want to commit her to
carpentry as well
and throw that on her plate too because
i was worried that we were gonna get the
props done in time so then it's like
okay now we're hiring out
a set carpenter to come in
um now we're a studio yeah now it's
getting out it's real
yeah but i you know i like it's we have
to make a call
and i still and i i still feel like
that's something we could do for that
wall and i think we're moving in that
direction
yeah but just for right now
the the best solution seem to be let's
just do the temporary paper rolls
um obviously with the inherent flaws
that those have
but um i'd like to do that eventually is
do it do a problem i do think the paper
will be fine because of where we the
where the actors have to stand on the
green screen anyways for lighting
purposes they're not even going to be
close to the wall yeah so it's kind of
like if they find themselves getting
back there to where they would step on
the paper that's where they're not
supposed to be anyways because of just
lighting purposes
so and yeah like you said the space
issue literally it just the way we're
going to lay it out it could just roll
back up and still have all that space
snoop snoop has a really nice green
screen oh yes he does
he saw that we saw that he's a big old
big old warehouse yeah that thing is
awesome dude that guy's full of green
screen tips he's got he just stopped
talking about it yeah he definitely yeah
he loves green
he's got the green
well he's on he's got the green while
he's on the green you know what i mean
yeah should we just go use his behind
the green and in front of the girl i
don't know what you mean um
no dude honestly i'm just happy we have
a green screen now like that but hey it
feels like a film studio now you know
yeah and and the the the i was very
impressed jordan with the way that you
guys were able to get it so
smooth when you sanded it i didn't think
that would pay as many dividends but
then after the two coats of paint and
how
like nicely it's just diffusing the
light it's
that's starting to feel like
professional level wall right there yeah
thanks that's really nice next step
carpentry next step next step
yeah
so
it really just comes down to you know
you gotta basically take
a bunch of
uh
triangular pieces of wood and then cut
them all out at the exact same angle
and then find you know what like a like
an eight
plywood or a quarter inch plywood
probably eighth inch and then just
bend it onto there yep yeah it's like a
bend wood kind of deal
yeah
i feel like that's like maybe next
season of son of a [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
i feel like we can we can do we get our
storage unit
right jake
and you know then you have the
opportunity to see how much we'll use it
the rest of the year you know yeah and
the whole idea behind this show is we
just continue to make it better
each season
each each time we go through the the
cycle of creating it like we just we
apply what we learned and we make it a
little bit better each time
and by the time we get to season three
four five like
you know
it's it's gonna be
it's not even gonna look like season one
in terms of its its quality
yeah
can't wait to be crazy yeah we're
talking about the son of a dungeon by
the way i don't know if people picked up
on that but yeah the old son of a
dungeon on the website yeah have you
heard of it
ever heard of it corridor digital.com
carterdigito.com all right
does anyone have any last minute facts
yeah actually oh yeah
i'm gonna review with one last sick
joshua tree fact here number two okay
here we go
[Music]
the town of joshua tree has some pretty
funky sculptures all right guys have a
good one see you next week nice funky
sculptures wait was that it really yeah
funky sculpture what your mind isn't
blown oh man all right all right i'm
gonna make up facts about joshua tree
okay ready
i'm ready okay i gotta find the right
chord for this
find the joshua tree cord oh that's it
right there yeah joshua's chords oozes
josh
joshua two things about him we know he
likes chords and he likes trees
that's something joshua tree you can
find a mouse
in joshua tree there aren't any houses
in josh gosh i can't play at this
three-four timing
in joshua tree you can find a mouse
in joshua tree there
a house
in joshua tree there's the ghost of an
old man he's gonna take you
to the promised land
he stole matt's soul then he came on
back
he sounded like a cougar in fact
was the man
thanks um i i think the ai articles were
uh the best form of improv in this one
yeah
they improv themselves over there dude
just make a whole ai band where
everything is ai generated yeah you have
to play it
oh yeah that would be fun actually make
all the lyrics next time
all right everybody thanks for joining
thanks for watching thanks for listening
and uh we'll see you right here back
next week on the corridor cast take care
of yourselves
or are we good let's fly away time to
fly
we're going to fly away okay here we go
there's a fly away song
[Music]
wow this is i hope this is the whole
outro right here
i hope so too it will be it is and
that's a cut and that's a cat and that's